I really struggled with how to cover
this story of a group of Magha
hat-wearing Trump supporting high school
students from Covington Kentucky who
surrounded and mocked a Native American
military veteran at a Washington DC
rally because at first I saw posts on
Twitter and Facebook about how the only
perpetrators here were the entitled
smirking privileged mostly white
anti-abortion Catholic school kids and
how it was wrong that they surrounded
this Native American protester in this
intimidating way I also started seeing
posts with a very different perspective
which was the kids did nothing wrong the
problem was that there was instigation
not only by Nathan Phillips the Native
American military veteran who was
singing and playing a drum but also by
so-called black Muslims who were not
actually black Muslims and we'll get to
that a little bit later and that
actually these kids should be applauded
for not becoming violent when they were
approached by a very hostile crowd the
truth is neither of those extremes and
we are now fortunately getting some more
nuance on the story and I know that
probably everyone will be upset with me
for my understanding of the story but as
I've always done on the program I'm not
going to give you anything other than my
honest and genuine perspective so let's
get into it
this all happened after an indigenous
peoples march and an anti-abortion march
both in Washington DC sort of collided
okay
and I could focus on the core singing of
the culture under Trump I could talk
about education as the catalyst here or
violence we could make it about racism
and xenophobia we could make it about
Catholic schools and parenting and
social class and entitlement and it
would be a story about all of those
things but this one actually mostly is a
story about toxic partisan politics
combined with elements of all of that
other stuff this is the last show that
would be caught doing the both sides are
to blame thing when that's not actually
the case okay when it comes to take your
pick fake news it's not both sides the
right is overwhelming
the perpetrator and perpetuator of fake
news when it comes to voter suppression
it's not both sides it's the right that
has figured out that they benefit from
fewer people voting and it's mostly
almost exclusively the right it's trying
to hold down the boat but I went back
and I took a look at this nearly
two-hour video of the incident in
Washington DC and there is no shortage
of blame to go around here for what went
on and what's really important here is
that one person or groups wrongs don't
justify anyone elses wrongs here this is
not a defense of these maggot wearing
kids and we'll get to that but the point
is the story that the only thing to
comment on here is these maggot at
wearing kids who were standing around a
Native American protester is simply
wrong and even the New York Times which
is no bastion of right-wing conspiracy
theories is saying that the full video
part of which we're playing now for
people tells a very different story than
just that initial piece of the video
that went viral the initial piece that
went viral was a Native American
military veteran Nathan Phillips beating
a drum and singing surrounded by a group
of young mostly white teenagers that
looked like they came not from an
anti-abortion rally but from a Trump
rally where they spent all of their
allowance money on Trump apparel and
hats right and in fact in the video you
see at one point that one of the kids is
standing about 12 inches from Nathan
Phillips is faced with this ludicrous
smirk that was at first the only part of
the video that got attention and it
should have gotten attention because
these kids are standing around one guy
in a way that looks intimidating they're
entitled smirks should piss anyone off
it certainly pissed me off their school
is investigating what took place the
school says they'll take appropriate
action these are kids who also are
pictured in other stories that have come
out about them at a basketball game for
example against a mostly black team
screaming at the black players some of
them had painted their entire bodies
basically instead of blackface it was
like a black body there's every
indication that these kids are
extraordinarily annoying entitled
ignorant clowns enabled by their parents
teachers chaperones whoever else's
around them that is a story here but to
pretend that they simply showed up
looking for trouble while no one else
was misbehaving and there were no other
factors here would be wrong and I'm not
going to do that first of all there are
numerous disputes about how they even
ended up in the same spot as the Native
American protester here
there were also pro-choice people who
were not behaving perfectly here there
are reports that indigenous peoples
protesters were yelling go back to
Europe to these white kids that's
actually on video that's insane and that
needs to be denounced there was a group
of they were called by some people black
Muslims but they're not they're black
Israelites who were proselytizing in the
very very inflammatory way that they do
yelling at everybody including at these
kids they if you're not familiar with
the black Israelites they're a group of
black Americans who claims that they are
the true descendants of the Israelites
and sort of in a sense the real Jews
although there's sort of a crossover
group between being Jews and Christians
but really what they're known for is
being inflammatory Street Preachers
which they chose to do at a central
point between two conflicting political
rallies reports include that the black
Israelites started arguing with the magg
of kids they were reportedly calling
them child molested [ __ ] dirty ass
crackers demon animals future school
shooters and racist bastards and at a
certain point in all of this Nathan
Phillips shows up when the black
Israelites are taunting the kids and he
walks into the crowd of students
choosing to do this he could have opted
to walk in a different way from the
video that I saw Nathan Phillips walked
to the kids and the kids just stood
there there are people reporting that
there were chants of build the wall
against the indigenous peoples that's
disgusting and that of course proves
that the border wall has never actually
been about border security because if it
were you wouldn't be yelling that at
Native Americans it's about xenophobia
and racism and it's vile but the problem
I have with this Pat is that it became
an Internet mob with people cherry
picking out of a two-hour video trying
to identify some of these underage kids
who of course bear significant
responsibility themselves but also our
kids they're the product of their
parents where were the chaperones why
did the school allow them to go to an
anti-choice rally dress like they're
coming from a Trump rally
so I'm not here to rank who did the
worst thing or to say who's more to
blame and I'm not saying that everyone
is equally to blame but what's clear to
me is that I can't think of anyone who
behaved particularly appropriately here
and I am with you and being disgusted
with the magic id's
I am with you in being disgusted by
everything we're learning about things
that have taken place at basketball
games and their behavior but we can't
pretend Pat that they were the unique
and sole instigators here and there were
certainly a bunch of misunderstandings
when you take a look at even that entire
two-hour clip you may not come away
knowing exactly what happened because
it's just not the best video quality not
the best audio quality one thing I will
point out though is it's unclear that
nathan phillips went when he walked up
to those those group of kids like i
don't know if they necessarily thought
that he was being combative or what he
was trying to do because they responded
like it was some sort of pep rally like
it was like maybe nathan phillips was
like playing along with them i don't
know i think you have to kind of give
the kids at least and out on that one
because i don't know if they realize if
they were being offensive or if the
situation was going to escalate but
certainly the responsibility does not
bear solely on them i know that there
are people on the Left who are going to
be mad at me how dare i questioned the
initial narrative how dare I question
the narrative that places blame only on
the kids I think that these kids are
quite frankly and the more we learn
about other things that have happened
involving their school it's absolutely
horrible but we we need to be full in
our reporting and I think in the long
run everybody loses by pushing a
narrative that's increasingly
demonstrably false based on the video if
you disagree with me I do want to hear
from you